(tapping)
- It's not every day that
you'll see an amputee
walking along with a peg leg,
and then begin to tap dance.
My name is Evan Ruggiero,
and I am a one-legged tap dancer.
It's fun!
I started tap dancing
when I was six-years-old.
It's something that I fell in love with.
I knew that tap dancing
would always be something
that I wanted to do for
the rest of my life.
When I was 19-years-old,
I had a pain in my right leg.
I was diagnosed with
osteosarcoma, bone cancer.
And on May 21st, 2010,
I had my right leg
amputated above-the-knee.
I was devastated.
I just thought: how could a tap dancer
be diagnosed with cancer in his leg?
I remember my tap teacher
showing me footage
of Peg Leg Bates,
who was a great tap dancer
way back in the day.
You know, had it not been for that footage,
I would've never thought
that I could tap dance again.
(tapping)
When I put that peg leg
on for the first time,
and I started making those rhythms,
I felt a part of me that came back
and I felt like my old self.
Woo!
I was able to teach
myself how to dance again.
I just let muscle memory kick back in,
and I tried not to think about making
a step-hop-step with my peg leg,
but just peg-hop-peg,
and changing around the
vocabulary of the step.
I perform in New York City.
There's definitely been an audible gasp
in the audience once or twice
while I've walked out on stage.
(cheering)
(tapping)
Tap dancing is very personal.
It's very much about the emotion.
(cheering)
A lot of times you can
tell when a tap dancer
is happy by the way he's dancing.
Despite having a diagnosis with cancer,
I was able to overcome that,
and I was able to go back to the things
that I loved the most.
So, it's always gonna be
a very different emotion
that is tied to the art form.
(cheering)